das hier ist nur ein Bruchteil der
heutehs wo wir über die groco abgekotzt
haben was für ein dummer dummer
Fehler mein genialer Vorschlag SPD raus
aus der Ampel und Spiel den Boss in
einer neuen groco na ist das
was aber wär es da nicht jetzt an der
Zeit die Bazooka mal wieder rauszuholen
zu sagen Grüne FDP war schön mit euch
dann pustet sie Weg um in ihrer
Terminologie auch zu bleiben in meiner
Terminologie
kopfkilo lass das so ein flotter Dreier
hat irgendwann seinen Reiz verloren und
dann geht's wieder heim zu Mutti und
Mutti heißt in dem Sinne die die CDU
also wieder das solide das das also wenn
dann aber nur wenn SPD oben liegt ich
wir sind beide Sauerländer me zunächst
sind beide Sauerländer deshalb kenne ich
ih sehr gut und deshalb sage ich
ne jetzt weint a mann das war nicht so
gemeint welche Erinnerung haben sie an
die
groko%
menschenung in Deut wir haben schon
einiges
bewegt überlegen was jetzt genau im
Einzelnen also Digitalisierung kann es
nicht sein
Windkraftausbau kann es auch nicht sein
trenbau auch
nicht helfen sie mir
was war das schönste Erlebnis mit der
CDU als in der großen Koalition waren
als es vorbei war sie sind Deutschlands
beliebtester Politiker wenn das die
Umfrage sagen im Augenblick wohl ja da
habe ich nur eine Frage warum sind sie
dann in SPD eine witzige Frage weil wir
gute richtig gute Leute haben sie als
als bauministerin sind ja vertraut mit
Sachen die nicht klappen jetzt kommen
wir auf die Ampel zu sprechen wer es
nicht an der Zeit jetzt endlich friedich
MZES go zu geben und zu sagen okay wir
machen es nein das ist auch noch ein
bisschen zu früh heute morgen am
Parteitag um 9 uh da ist meine
scherzfähigkeit noch nicht so ausgeprägt
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen jetzt ist
natürlich so wie sehr nervt sie die
FDP von Skala 1 bis 10 ja ze wie sehr
nervt sie trotzdem von den Hintergrund
der aktuellen Geschehnisse die FDP gar
nicht so gar nicht überhaupt nicht sie
finden Christian l richtig toll mit dem
was er ma ich finde alle in der
Koalition richtig toll ja jetzt sehe ich
gerade wie ihre Nase wächst ich nicht
ist schön t das ist eine Sadomaso
Geschichte die ich hier Abrufe aber Sie
müssen sich
entscheiden geht das nicht mal wieder
mit dem allein
regieren träum
weiter hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf
Gefällt mir drückt und den Kanal
abonniert zeige ich euch meinen
lautesten Schrei für das menschliche
Gehör ist ja zwar nicht wahrzunehmen
aber ich würde eure Hunde kurz
rausbringen okay
[Musik]
fertig